les extraterrestres sont parmi nous ne
seriez pas de plus en plus d'américains
croient dur comme fer aux ovnis une
croyance relayé ces derniers mois par la
télévision le cinéma internet ou les
jeux vidéo mais le symbole le plus fort
de cet engouement
c'est la zone 51 un périmètre ultra
secret qui se trouve à l'intérieur d'une
base militaire dans le nevada de
nombreux américains sont en effet
persuadés que le gouvernement et cache
des vaisseaux spatiaux et des
extraterrestres martine laroche-joubert
et bruno girodon se sont donc lancés sur
la piste de ces êtres venus d'ailleurs
dressant au passage le portrait d'une
amérique un peu déboussolée et les c'est
un endroit tellement secret est
sensiblement le plus secret world
jamais entendu parler de la règle 51
je ne suis jamais allé
[Musique]
184 le gouvernement a exproprié 36
l'hectare entourent la base les citoyens
américains ne pouvait plus voir cette
base et tout le monde s'est demandé
pourquoi
bée ware il ment ils nous disent que
cette base n'est pas là mais nous savons
avec certitude que oui elle est bien là
on a commencé à entendre des histoires
de soucoupe volante je me suis dit que
c'était absurde mais j'ai en lui a dédié
la question plus jeune étudiant est plus
je trouvais des gens qui disaient avoir
entendu des choses sur cet indice
by qu'il existe une faille de vie
intelligente ailleurs et peut-être
qu'elle existe la dass 51 plus grand
hangar de la base est connue sous le nom
de hangars 18,7 en l'air d'aviation
probablement assez vaste pour contenir
un 747
j'ai rencontré bob lazare des bus 89
grâce à un ami commun raconter une
histoire incroyable je me suis dit que
si seulement une toute petite partie de
cette histoire était vraie ce serait
probablement le cuir en scoop de tous
les droits
georges klein journaliste à las vegas
c'est lui qui révèle au grand public le
mystère de la zone 51 dans le nevada et
bien neuf soucoupe volante
le disque volant qui sont d'origine
extraterrestre autre vedette de ce
dossier bob lazare la mort filmée dans
l'ombre pour des raisons de sécurité
puis à visage découvert il se prétend
physicien affirme avoir travaillé près
de la zone 51
et vu des militaires étudier des
vaisseaux spatiaux dans des hangars sous
la montagne et les hangars sont tous
reliés les uns aux autres dans de
grandes ouvertures pour passer de l'un à
l'autre
donc au total neuf vaisseaux spatiaux et
tout était différent comme s'ils
n'avaient rien compris
est-ce que vous avez menti sciemment
lorsque vous avez déclaré avoir vu
fonctionner la propulsion antigravité
non vrai ou faux
bob lazare passe avec succès le test du
détecteur de mensonges mais si la
fabuleuse sur ses diplômes
le doute s'installe mais le pentagone ne
dément pas ces affirmations
[Musique]
pour en savoir plus nous profitons d'une
journée portes ouvertes sur la base
aérienne de nellis à las vegas nous
sommes ici à 250 km de la zone 51
[Musique]
à défaut de venir ce sont les avions les
plus sophistiqués du monde dont le
bombardier furtif et d'autres qui sont
présentés ici ceux dont les essais ont
eu lieu dans la base militaire mais
l'armée fait tout pour épaissir le
mystère de la base 51 en refusant de
répondre à nos questions et peut voler
vers le monde ici par de la zone 51
je ne peux rien dire c'est quelque chose
dont on ne parle pas
[Musique]
si oui on ne sait rien tout ça ça il
nous en parle jamais
[Musique]
et vraiment diverses film on parle de la
zone 51
[Musique]
vous savez quelque chose à ce sujet je
ne peux pas répondre à vos questions
pourquoi
[Musique]
je ne peux pas répondre à vos questions
unique opportunité pour apercevoir de
loin la zone 51 à 50 km après deux
heures de marche dans la montagne 1995
le gouvernement a encore agrandi le
périmètre de sécurité
mais les curieux affluent avec chaque
cas une tentative d'explication pour cet
engouement l'une des choses
intéressantes à propos de la base 51
c'est que étant donné que la base n'a
jamais eu d'existence officielle et
qu'on a jamais donné la moindre
information à ce sujet
cela laisse libre cours à l'imagination
des gens ils peuvent inventer ce qui
pourrait être là au lendemain de la
guerre froide maintenant que des russes
sont nos ennemis
s'il n'ya plus de menace extérieure il
est intéressant de voir qu'on
s'intéresse maintenant énormément au
sauna c'est un peu comme si cet intérêt
pour les créatures venues d'ailleurs
avait remplacé notre hauteur des russes
et cette base qui se trouve derrière moi
c'est en fait le lieu principal de la
paranoïa de la guerre froide et du grand
secret depuis 40 ans tous et intéresse
toute cette fascination se reporte
désormais sur cette base au coeur de
l'amérique profonde
une centaine d'habitants la plupart
retraités
à l'extrémité de rachael l'auberge de
l'italienne un jeu de mots sur le petit
extraterrestre
[Musique]
et
le rendez-vous des curieux mais aussi de
tous ceux qui attendent l'arrivée de
l'apocalypse avec le débarquement des
extraterrestres
jo le patron de l'auberge adversaires du
nouvel ordre mondial mais surtout du
pouvoir central de washington pat sa
femme mariée avec lui depuis 16 ans
partagent ses idées politiques étroits
farouchement aux extraterrestres
deux accueilli avec chaleur les
fanatiques venus des quatre coins des
états unis échafaude des hypothèses
recueilli des confidences s'échangent
des photos plus ou moins mystérieuse
[Musique]
la plupart de ces photos proviennent du
musée des ovnis orlando en floride
ici c'est un document vraiment
exceptionnel vous voyez billy cox qui
est parti pêcher en bateau vous voyez là
il vient d'attraper un poisson et on
voit un objet ici ce n'était pas du tout
prévu nous préparer avez vous vu quelque
chose vous même
bien sûr la première chose qui nous est
arrivé à mon mari à moi c'était vous
voyez il apporte juste derrière moi un
faisceau lumineux à traverser cette
porte
il faisait environ 8 cm de diamètre ce
rayon a été projeté dans la pièce sur
une longueur de 2 mètres ça il me et
tout l'encadrement de la porte
nous avons tous les deux regarder à
l'extérieur mais il n'y avait rien il
faisait environ - 32 or rien ne bougeait
n'y avait rien pas de traces de brûlé
sur la porte
rien absolument rien mais nous avons
ressenti une présence on se sent quand
on est observé par quelqu'un mon mari a
dit à haute voix
installez vous faites comme chez vous
vous serez toujours les bienvenus
e
les extraterrestres cachée de la
montagne avec la complicité du
gouvernement une obsession partagé par
un grand nombre d'américains persuadé
qu'on leur cache la vérité qui payent
tous les gouvernements du monde
maintiennent les peuples dans
l'obscurité sur ce qui est important
mais qu'est ce qu'ils cherchent
pourquoi les styles les gens dans
l'obscurité c'est ça la vraie question
c'est ce désir
cette volonté de savoir qui hante tous
les peuples de la terre garçon qu'on
nous laisse donc travailler main dans la
main et peut-être arrivons-nous à
trouver une solution mais qu'est-ce qui
nous nourrit ce qui nous manque c'est la
vérité c'est ça qui nous manque chose et
c'est pour ça que les chercheurs de
vérité viennent ici pour tenter de
glaner un soupçon de vérité dans une
conversation dans un débat
principaux accusés de la dissimulation
de la vérité le pouvoir central et les
présidents des états unis
dans le même mouvement de révolte on
mêle aussi la tentative par ce pouvoir
d'interdire la vente libre des armes
le bar de l'italienne mélange de petite
politique et de petits business
nous avons des panneaux pour les piétons
sont rigolos sur les achats bio nous
avions plusieurs teams d'extraterrestres
nous avons leur modèle et ils m'ont
avoué au site de plus petit et ça c'est
un de mes trucs préféré c'est un sweat
shirt mais je rends aussi en tee shirt
et sadi occupez vous bien la terre on
nous le ferons
c'est un message assez percutant
pourquoi vous êtes noir est né ici
pourquoi je me suis arrêté ici où ma
femme et moi même nous nous sommes
toujours intéressés aux soucoupes
volantes que vos extraterrestres et on a
pensé que c'était vraiment l'endroit où
il fallait venir si on voulait les voir
ça fait une journée que nous sommes ici
on n'a encore rien vu mais c'est un
endroit très intéressant d'être envoyé
aux extraterrestres une fosse du 13 tu
dois trust si j'y crois j'y crois
effectivement j'espère bien voir quelque
chose aujourd'hui peut-être ce soir bien
ici vient dire bonjour et vous vous
croyez ou soucoupe volante et les
extraterrestres oppose sais pas quelle
forme et quelle taille il aurai je ne
crois pas qu'il ressemblerait à toutes
ces photos qu'on voit avec ces tête
d'insecte
je crois à la vie l'espace et du temps
nous ne sommes pas seuls dans l'univers
nous sommes ici à une dizaine de
kilomètres de la base militaire carrier
john expert en assurances de chicago
suivent le chemin obligé des amateurs
d'extraterrestres
la frontière de la zone interdite au
delà la base militaire la mieux protégée
des états unis avec voiture blanche
kythera et gardes armés pour repousser
les indiscrets
une base de près de dix mille kilomètres
carrés à l'intérieur de laquelle se
trouverait la zone 51
une base qui emploierait plus de 2000
personnes
lauren la mémoire de rachael la
meilleure amie de pâtes lorraine qui est
ici depuis 20 ans et possède des
croyance bien ancrée
je crois en dieu et je crois vraiment
qu'il a un plan je crois que les ovnis
faut peut-être partie de ce plan la
raison pour laquelle nous n'avons pas
encore vu ces créatures c'est parce
qu'il ne vais pas trop nous effrayer car
donc pour l'instant il ne nous montre
que la partie mécanique les créatures
viendront après parce qu'elles sont
différentes de vous et moi sont
probablement pas si moche que ça
les ailes sont différentes et les gens
ont toujours peur de la différence
quelle qu'elle soit
un habitué du bar tchèque nous demande
de l'accompagner pour se prêter à son
jeu favori
[Applaudissements]
je déteste voir ces gens qui harcèlent
les gardes parce que jusqu'à présent on
a eu beaucoup de chance il n'y a pas eu
d'accident mais un jour ou l'autre on
tombera sur la personne sur dix mille
qui appuiera sur la gâchette et là ça va
faire mal
presque tous les soirs
jack se rend à la frontière de la base
militaire pour provoquer les gardes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
on est en train de jouer un petit jeu il
est clair il est clair et on voit qu'ils
se fatiguent le premier
la lumière est un peu plus vite que la
sienne donc c'est probablement lui qui a
pas non pas le premier ni dernière nous
avons fait la même chose et en moins
d'une minute il a fait marche arrière et
il a disparu
il n'a même pas allumer son projecteur
[Musique]
oh
le centre de recherche sur la zone 51
créé par un particulier
glen campbell un informaticien dans ce
village où tout le monde y croit
il est le pourfendeur des légendes se
trouve juste à côté d'un des plus grands
centres d'exercice de guerre du monde
libre tous les avions tous les pilotes
de combat viennent ici s'entraîner au
largage de bombes combat entre avions de
chasse et aux attaques aériennes de
toutes sortes
c'est tout ça au dessus de russell juste
au dessus de cette capitale des ovnis
ceci provoque beaucoup de lueur dans le
ciel cela produit des flamboiement bgc
la lumière des bombardements en fait
tout ce que l'on voit habituellement à
la télévision quand il y à des guerres
ça vous donne de très bons jeunes ici
vous avez envie de voir des ovnis je dis
souvent qu'en fait c'est lors de la
première ici que l'on voit le plus
devenir moins personnellement j'habite
ici depuis deux ans et demi et je n'ai
jamais vu quoi que ce soit
d'inexplicable
[Musique]